CLINT BARTON
Kate. Let's give them hell.
♪♪
JEREMY RENNER
It's been a wonderful way to discover
a lot more of the
humanity of who Clint Barton is.
HAILEE STEINFELD
He was wonderful in showing me the ropes
and collaborating with
me in finding this
amazing dynamic between Clint and Kate.
KATE BISHOP
You're Hawkeye!
CLINT BARTON
Who the hell are you?
TRINH TRAN
Kate Bishop saw what Clint Barton
can do as Hawkeye.
That really inspired
her to be like him.
♪♪
KEVIN FEIGE
Seeing the comic page come to life
on the screen is what has
excited me for the past 20 years.
What is equally exciting
is the enthusiasm
that the actors themselves
bring to evolving these characters.
FLORENCE PUGH
My relationship with Hailee is
our little heartbeats
throughout our stories.
KATE BISHOP
Stop making me like you.
YELENA BELOVA
I'm sorry I can't help it.
BRAD WINDERBAUM
It's amazing what happens when you let
actors like Jeremy Renner
really have the space
to explore their
character and their backstory.
JEREMY RENNER
First two weeks of shooting this,
I've said more than I've
said in the entire MCU Universe.
TRINH TRAN
There's so much great source material.
There's a lot more story to tell.
♪♪